it's not a secret what weapon systems
and equipment the ukrainian military has
where they keep it though most certainly
is
this camp is top secret hidden in woods
in the dinettes region of eastern
ukraine
sky news is the first media organization
to ever film here
if there is going to be a resistance to
an invading russian force
it'll come from here
this is the country's main tank
battalion in the south east as the
tension continues to grow over a
potential invasion the tank crews are
undergoing intense training
they're working on evasion tactics
knowing that they'll be outgunned by the
russian forces more sophisticated
equipment and more importantly its sheer
numbers
the military's top brass are coming to
inspect this base
the tanks are usually concealed in
positions in miles of snowy forest
with a gas turbine engine they sound
more like a jet fighter than the old
diesel-powered tank
these t-80 b1 v vehicles are upgraded
versions of older designs they're widely
regarded as better than the tanks used
by the russians
and the ukraine military has been taking
delivery of as many as they can get
since the separatist uprising in dalbas
and the russian annexation of crimea
an investment that now appears wise
these are the most sophisticated
attacks available to the ukrainian
military it's why they keep them hidden
it's going to be vitally important
that they're operational and are kept
safe in case the russians invade it's
the best protection they've got
the tanks carve up the earth as they
maneuver bear in mind it's pretty much
frozen
both armies could quite easily find
themselves bogged down
it's not lost on any of these tank crews
how intense things could get
everyone's talking about a potential
russian invasion
are you preparing for this i mean has
life changed at all or is everything
just carry on as normal
not
[Music]
experts do not believe that if an
invasion takes place there will be
actual world war ii style tank battles
on open planes
tactics and missile systems are
different now
but in the current uncertainty of what
may happen
absolutely nothing can be ruled out
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine